Hình họ thứ 3 hội đồng nhân dân thành phố chiming sẽ tập trung xem sát thảo lợt
nánh giá tạng diện tình hình phát triển kinh tế xá hội, khu phòng an ninh
thu chi ngân sách nổ từ công sấu tháng đầu năm.
Đồng thời xác định các nhiệm vụ giải pháp sọng tâm để hoàn thành các mục tiêu
chỉ tiêu năm hàng những công trong hay sấu.
Lông thời xam sẽ kế hoa tổ từ công Trung hạn, giải loạn hàng những công trong
hay sấu hàng những công trong bác mươi, và truy true công đầu tư các giãng sọng điểm.
Tạo kết sở để chiến khai các công chiến hả tương trí lợt.
Tăng kết nối vùng và thuộc đại phát triển kinh tế xá hội của thành phố.
Khi học này sẽ xem sát quy định năm 2018 lỗi dùng thuộc thẩm quyền của hội đồng nhân dân thành phố chiming.
Trong đó có nhiều cơ trẻ chính sách và giãng có ý nghĩa quan sọng lối với sự phát triển của thành phố trong giai đảng tới.
Đáng truy ý, việc xem sát truy true nổ từ bốn công trình, giãng sọng điểm dự kiến khở công nhân dự kiến nhận năm
năm thành phố xa gòn ra điện.
Vinh dự mang tên truy tịch hổ chiming.
Lông thời xam sẽ một số chính sách ăn sinh xá hội thiết thật.
Trong đó có chính sách hội trở người sự dụng phương viện vẫn tại hành khách công cộng bằng xa miết.
Khi học cũng xem sát quy định các chính sách triển khổ trở lối với người hành động không chuyên sách ở cấp sát.
Nơi hành động không chuyên sách người tham gia hành động tại khu phố,
Up Thôn của dân cơ tổ trường tổ phó tổ dân phố.
Tổ nhân dân tự quản tổ dân cơ tự quản, thôi tham gia công tác giao thực hiện chủ trường sắp sế tổ chức bộ mại và sắp sếm lại khu phố.
Up Thôn của dân cơ.
Bán hành các chính sách về phụ cấp hội trở kinh phía vật lộn lối với người lượng tham gia công tác ở khu phố,
Up Thôn của dân cơ tổ tham mọi hình mới.